[Music]
you don't know how to play the kazoo
you're not my girlfriend anymore do a
nice welcome to this video we got two
cameras set up hey how you doing hey how
you doing hey how's good point
hey you're my girlfriend and I'm gonna
satisfy my girlfriend show me what you
got the first item I say something red
how does that feel how satisfied are you
right now
oh you're supposed to do ahh oh my god
you're not satisfied
I feel so satisfied oh I'm not satisfied
now I prefer the lemon trees I think you
should smack me with it
see thank you like that slap now Jesus
okay this is you broke your [ __ ] alright
how would you rate that satisfactory
x-ray out of ten yeah why okay we need
to step up the satisfaction is that what
you're saying more satisfaction we have
the play funk you can make Barney's
penis with it what are ya okay fine no
this is not about me this is me
satisfying you okay
I try harder I need to try harder
everyone alright well then prepare for
the next one are you ready for the
ultimate the ultimate satisfaction I
think you're gonna be quite satisfied
okay
alright you trust me you gotta hold it
like this and then go crazy no no okay
now playing with the wheel hey what are
you doing
whoa it's magnetic oh [ __ ] I'm satisfied
four-year oh dude that guy I'm a move
down
this is can i this is all set yeah I
fine you know a man of great satisfier
II doesn't give away his way man it
doesn't give away he's six and a half I
would give this a 10 out of 10 I'm
waiting can I know you need to chillax
chillax
yeah here we go do you now change stuff
let me tell you about kinetic energy
this is quite interesting the cont
goddamnit no no I mean laugh
[Music]
kinetic energy is preserved by the by
lifting one of them that is so cool she
needs to be satisfied well that's not oh
my god so precious about it yeah this is
the name I'm not gonna touch that [ __ ]
that looks disgusting yeah I'm cringing
I think it's disgusting I don't want to
look at that thing
it's ruining it's too good these it
could it not it could have been a ten
out of ten
yeah stop I can't just take that away
just put it back you want it it makes me
cringe I think it's disgusting
can I can I are you ready to be Oh No
what the hell you prank me oh okay all
right here we go are you ready to be
satisfied are you ready to be satisfied
are you ready to be satisfied
Wow okay close your eyes
I think so far have you been satisfied
here you go prepare to be satisfied your
hair whinnies yeah it's just if if it's
satisfying for you I will do it Oh No
who's that your copra house oh oh holy
[ __ ] look at it oh my god
oh my god I will kill it for you my god
um
that's right okay so tell me what this
sign means
[Music]
[Music]
okay sign is going in Wow wait wait I
want to do what they do online on
Instagram what are they doing in
sobriety so that it looks like a beauty
blender a Beauty Blender yeah do you
blow torch it afterwards yeah we need
nice this is not smooth enough
[Music]
that's not a knife that's a knife gomez
oh my god oh [ __ ] it keeps long enough
that seems to be a problem when you try
and satisfy your girlfriend all right
let's see if I can sir
all right show that camera look at that
castle
you can she can even hold it Wow
[Music]
Wow this is way too bright now the real
satisfaction McGee wait just wait I'm
bringing you guys
[Music]
okay max yeah we're in the sensory
deprivation tank I don't feel any are
you ready for the ultimate satisfaction
are you ready
Wow whoa yeah me too I meet Arab damn it
no no it goes on forever
whoa oh oh this has been satisfying
girlfriend
what portal we didn't need the tank for
that thank you guys for watching leave a
like if you enjoyed check out another
video right here